[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استاهل هذا
بابره الع
[موسيقى]
من موسكو الرئيسان الصيني والروسيه
واكداني على عالم جديد متعدد الاقطاب
وواشنطن تعلق يتحالفون ضد امريكا
الحل الطارئ لازمه كريدي السويس ينعش
الاسهم الاسهم البنوك الامريكيه وبنوك
مركزيه عالميه تتحرك لتوفير السيول
الدولاريه
[موسيقى]
عمران خان في مقابلات خاصه مع العربيه
هناك مئه قضيه مرفوعه ضدي ودوافعها
السياسيه
ترامب يتهم المدعي العام بمن هاتم بتدخل
في انتخابات 2024 والاخير قد يوجه اتهامات
خلال يومين
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من موسكو حيث يزور الرئيس
الصيني تشييد جين بينج العاصمه الروسيه
ويلتقي فيها نظيره
وهي اول زياره للرئيس منذ بدء الحرف في
اوكرانيا واول زياره الى موسكو منذ حوالي
اربع سنوات الاهداف المعلنه لزياره
تتحدث عن تعزيز العلاقات بين الحليفين
اضافه الى طرح خطه السلام بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا الخطه التي قال بوتين انه يرحب
بها وسيتسنى له مناقشاتها مع نظيره الصيني
اما عن التعليق الامريكي على الزياره فوصف
البيت الابيض المبادره الصينيه بانها
محاوله لمنح روسيا الوقت يشن هجوم جديد
مضيفا اي البيت الابيض انه لا توجد ثقه
بين روسيا والصين لكن التحالف بينهما موجه
ضد الولايات المتحده
لقد درسنا بعنايه مقترحاتك لحل الازمه
الحاده في اوكرانيا
ستتاح لنا الفرصه لمناقشه هذه المساله
وسنناقش بالطبع كل هذه القضايا بما في ذلك
مبادرتك بشكل عام ونحن نعلم انك تنطلق من
مبادئ العداله ومراعاه الاحكام الاساسيه
للقانون الدولي انت تدرك ايضا اننا
منفتحون دائما على عمليه التفاوض
وسيسهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بالطبع
في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه للنظام العالمي
وتعدد الاقطاب
بدورها قال الرئيس الصيني لنظيره الروسي
انه مقتنع بان الشعب الروسي سيدعمه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه وان روسيا
حققت نجاحا كبيرا في تحقيق الرخاء
والرفاهيه للبلاد
اعلم انه في العام المقبل ستنظم بلدك
انتخابات رئاسيه اخرى وبفضل قيادتكم
القويه حققت روسيا نجاحا كبيرا في تحقيق
الرخاء والرفاهيه للبلاد وانا متاكد من ان
الشعب الروسي سوف يدعمكم فيما تبذلونه من
جهود
وبعد وصوله للكريم لان قال الرئيس الصيني
ان هناك منطق تاريخي للعلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه مؤكدا ان التعاون الاستراتيجي
للبلدين يفرض وجود علاقات وثيقه
اهميه كبيره للعلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
وهناك منطق تاريخي وراء ذلك لاننا اكبر
دولتين متجاورتين بالاضافه الى اننا شركاء
استراتيجيون هذا يحدد ان لدينا علاقه
وثيقه للغايه مع بعضنا البعض
في زياره اولى منذ اعاده انتخابه لولايه
رئاسيه ثالثه وصل الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
وهذه الزياره قد تحدد مستقبل حرب اوكرانيا
تقول هنا صحيفه روسيه حرب اوكرانيا حاضره
بقوه على طاوله النقاش بين الزعيمين
الصيني والروسيه تستعد لمضاعفه الدور في
الصراع في الوقت الذي تحدثت فيه طبعا
الولايات المتحده عن ان الصين ستبدا
بارسال امدادات عسكريه الى موسكو وحذرت من
ذلك ولكن الامر لا يتعلق بتسليم اسلحه كما
يعتقد الامريكيون بل برغبه بكين في ان
تصبح وسيطا في صنع السلام بعدما حققت
نجاحا مهما بالاتفاق الاخير بين كل من
ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه حسب طبعا
الصحيفه الروسيه الرئيس الصيني يمكن ان
يقدم بديلا مختلفا وضمانات مختلفه وفق هذه
المبادره التي فرصه جديده لتحقيق السلام
من جانب اخر الرئيس الصيني يمتلك بعض
اسلحه الضغط على الجانب الاوكراني وعلى
راسها احتمالات امداد روسيا بالاسلحه هنا
مسؤولون الصينيون قالوا للصحيفه الروسيه
لماذا يمكن للغرب ان يصلح تايوان ولا يمكن
للصين تزويد روسيا بالاسلحه ولماذا لا
تجعل التعاون العسكري مع موسكو مرتبطا
بشكل مباشر بقضيه تايوان وفي حال فعلت
الصين ذلك فانه سيشكل اخبارا واخبارا سيئه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لانه اذا كان على
واشنطن ان تختار بين دعم كياف وتعيبي فان
الامريكيين سيختارون تايبي بالتاكيد وذلك
لانها هي قصه اقدم بكثير واكثر اهميه
بالنسبه لهم هذا الامر بحسب ايضا الصحيفه
سيدفع كياف الى التفكير بطريقه جديه وتبدا
هنا المشاورات مع موسكو وبناء عليه ستكون
ضربه قاسيه للغرب وسياساته
وفيعطي هذا الصين مكانه جديده بوصفها
صانعه للسلام العالمي والحديث هنا طبعا
للصحيفه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
التزامني مع قمه
ما هي خطه بكين المكونه من 12 بندا لتحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا والتي قال عنها شيء
انها تمثل اكبر قدر ممكن من وحده وجهات
نظر المجتمع الدولي في
خطته بكين لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا
استئنافه محادثات السلام
احترامه سياده كل الدول التخلي عن عقليه
الحرب البارده وقف الاعمال العدائيه ايجاد
حل للازمه الانسانيه حمايه المدنيين
وتبادل اسرى الحرب الحفاظ على سلامه
المنشات النوويه
تقليص الاخطار الاستراتيجيه تسهيل تصدير
الحبوب وقف العقوبات احاديه الجانب الحفاظ
على استقرار سلاسل الصناعه والتوريد دعم
مرحله اعاده الاعمار
قبل ذلك رحب وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي بمذكره التوقيت الدوليه ضد
الرئيس الروسي والتي تدعو الى اعتقاله
وانشاء محكمه دوليه لتحقيق في الحرب في
اوكرانيا حيث اكدت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان هذا القرار يبعث بالارتياح
للحديث اكثر عن هذه الزياره زياره الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو ينضم الينا من ابوظبي
عبر زوم
فيتاليين الدبلوماسي الاوكراني استاذ
فيتالي يعني هذه الزياره ومبادره السلام
الصينيه الموقف الاوكراني منها معروف
ومعلوم يعني منذ فتره بان لا جلوس ولا
سلام بدون اعاده الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
تعتبرونها محتله اليوم بعد هذه الزياره هل
تتوقعون ان يكون هناك اي تغيير بالموقف
الروسي
مساء الخير يا مشاهدينا الكرام مساء الخير
استوديو استاذه ليال نعم نحن نشدد على ان
استعاده وحده اراضي الاوكرانيه يجب ان
تكون في قلب جميع محادثات والجهود
الدبلوماسيه بما فيها الصينيه مهمه جدا ان
الصين تقول رسميا عن ضروره الحفاظ على
وحده واعراض اوكرانيا وهذا بالضبط ما ندعو
اليه نحن باستمرار وانطلاقا من هذا الموقف
المشترك نتوقع ان تستخدم بكين نفوذها على
موسكو والضغطها على بوتين
والذي اصبح الان رسميا مجرم الحرب
لاجبار روسيا على انهاء حربها العدوانيه
الاستعماريه ضد اوكرانيا وانسحاب قواتها
من ارضنا السياديه
وبالطبع نحن مستعدون للتعاون والحوار
الوثيق مع الصين لاستعاده السلام العادل
في اوكرانيا لمبادئ نطاق الامم المتحده
وقرارات الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
الاخيره بهذا الشعب تدعو الى الانسحاب
الفوري للقوات الروسيه من اراد اوكرانيا
واستعاده وعدد اراضي الدوله
بموضوع الضغط على روسيا وتحديدا على
الرئيس الروسي يعني هناك تشكيك كبير ان
كان من قبل سياسيين الاوكران او حتى
الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين بقدره بكين على
الضغط على الرئيس الروسي يعني الى لا
تستطيع الى مدى كبير ان تقوم بهذا الدور
اذا لم تستطع الضغط عليه ماذا سيكون موقف
اوكرانيا من هذه المبادره هل سيبقى على
حاله
نحن نعتقد ان اصبحت روسيا الان دوله
منبوذه عالميا ولقد انفقت موسكو عشرات
مليارات من الدولارات وقود من الزمن في
بناء نظام نفوذها العالمي ولقد دمر بوتين
كل ذلك خلال عام واحد من غزوه الفاشل
لاوكرانيا واليوم نشاهد كيف تتحول روسيا
الى مقاطعه صينيه يعني
تزداد قدرات الصينيه للضغط على روسيا
ارتكبت روسيا خطا فاضحا عندما قررت غزو
اوكرانيا واليوم هو وصمود اوكرانيا تلهم
جميع دول العالم
خصوصا ان الاعتماد الاقتصادي اليوم هو
اساسي على الصين بالنسبه للروس طيب بموضوع
المبادره الا تتخوفون من يعني دعم خصوصا
من قبل الدول الناشئه دول العالم الثالث
ودول اوروبيه حتى بسبب التداعيات
الاقتصاديه الكبيره لهذه الحرب على الدول
والتي بدانا يعني نشاهد تظاهرات والى غيره
في الدول الاوروبيه
ان الصين دوله العالميه الكبيره يجب ان
تكون مهتمه يعني باستقرار العالم يعني
بالدعم اوكرانيا واستعاده بعض الاراضينا
اذا نحن لا نتخوف ونحن لسنا خائفين من اي
شيء بعد 24 فبراير العام الماضيه ونحن
نصمت ونحن جاهزين للمقاومه ولتحرير ارضنا
بجميع الوسائل المتاحه لنا الدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه نعم شكرا لك استاذ
فيتاليين الدبلوماسي الاوكراني حدثتنا من
ابو ظبي
نبقى ايضا في ملفات الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن
ميدانيا حيث اعلن قائد قوات فاجنر ان
قواته تسيطر على 70% من باخموت مضيفا انه
اخبر الدفاع الروسيه بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتحضر لهجوم مضاد نهايه الشهر
الجاري بدورها القوات الروسيه تتقدم في
محيط بلده افديفيكا الاوكرانيه حسب تقارير
عسكريه وايضا تقارير غربيه وهدفها طبعا
قطع خط امداد القوات الاوكرانيه المزيد
بتقرير للزميل انس النماسي
قصف بعد الاخر هكذا تقدمت القوات الروسيه
نحو مدينه
التي قامت باجلاء من تبقى فيها من سكان
بعد ان اوشكت على ان تكون مدمره بالكامل
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه في تقرير لها
قالت ان القوات الروسيه تهدف الى السيطره
على المدينه لتتمكن من قطع خط امداد
القوات الاوكرانيه
هذه المدينه القريبه من باخموت كانت على
خط المواجهه منذ 2014
حينما بدا الصراع المسلح الروسي الاوكراني
في دامباس الروس يعتبرون مدينه ذات موقع
استراتيجي فاضافه الى قطع الامدادات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ستتمكن القوات
الروسيه والوحدات المواليه لها من جمهوريه
دونيتك المعترف بها فقط من موسكو من
الهجوم المباشر على منطقه فوليدار وحسب
وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه فان الروس قاموا
باربع هجمات ومائه 122 عمليه قصف على خلال
اخر 24 ساعه اما سيطره الروس على هذه
المدينه بحسب خبراء عسكريين فسيكون امرا
باهض الثمن ان اسم ماسي العربيه
نشرت وزارات دفاع الروسيه لقطات لاعمال
قتاليه لاطقم مدافحها
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه حيث ضرب
الجنود الروسي المواقع الخفيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه فالم
هذا هو طلبه الرئاسه الروسيه من المسؤولين
التوقف عن استخدام هواتف ايفون المصنعه من
قبل شركه ابل امريكيه بسبب مخاوف من ان
هذه الاجهزه قد تكون عرضه لخرق من وكالات
الاستخبارات الغربيه وفق ما كشفته وسائل
اعلام روسيه وسيتعين على كبار المسؤولين
الروس القيام بذلك في مارس الحالي هذا
وكشف الكريم بانه قد يزود اجهزه اخرى
بانظمه تشغيل مختلفه لتحل محل اجهزه ايفون
وتصدر الاشاره هنا الى ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لا يستخدم الهواتف الذكيه
بدورها شركه ابل لم تعلق على مطلب الرئاسه
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
الاقتصاديه انتعشت اليوم الاسهم الامريكيه
بعد صفقه بنك
للاستحواذ على منافسها الاصغر كردي سويس
في محاوله لتجنب المزيد من الاضطرابات
التي تهز السوق في البنوك العالميه
انتعالجه تتزامن مع تحرك منسق لبنوك
مركزيه عالميه لتوفير سيوله من الدولار
والبنوك المشاركه للبنك المركزي الفيدرالي
في امريكا وبنك كندا وبنك انجلترا وبنك
اليابان وبنك المركزيه الاوروبي والبنك
الوطني السويسري وهذه نظره مشاهدينا على
الاسهم
[موسيقى]
هل يعود ويشهد العالم ازمه عام 2008
الماليه الجواب لا طبعا بحسب خبراء بالرغم
من ان المخاوف العالميه من تداعيات انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي في الولايات المتحده
وصلت الى مصارف سويسريه ما دفع بنك يو بي
اس الى ابرام صفقه تاريخيه لشراء كريدي
سويس ولمنع انهيار ثاني اكبر مصرف
السويسري الذي تاسس قبل
167 عاما الحكومه السويسريه راعت صفقه
الشراء هذه الحمايه النظام المصرفي وهذه
الخطوه جاءت بعد ان استفادت طبعا سويسرا
وقبلها الولايات المتحده من تجربه الازمه
الماليه العالميه التي عصفت العالم بعام
2008 يقول هنا الخبراء الماليين الذين
شددوا على ان الازمه الماليه الراهنه
تختلف تماما عن ازمه عام 2008 لان الاسباب
تختلف ايضا ولكن حاله الهلع التي العملاء
ادت الى سحب مبالغ كبيره من المصارف مما
ادى الى تراجع البورصات وافهم المصارف في
اوروبا عقب صفقات كرادي سويس وحاله
الاضطراب واضطراب القطاع المصرفي ساهمت
ايضا بهبوط اسعار النفط الى ادنى مستوى في
15 شهرا والصمخاوف طبعا مشاهدينا من
احتمال ان تؤدي هذه الاضطرابات الى ركود
من شانه ان يؤدي الى تراجع الطلب على
النفط فضلا عن المخاوف من رفع محتمل
لاسعار الفائده وتحديدا في الولايات
المتحده هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
هذه السندات تم ايجادها كتفكره بعد
الازمه الماليه العالميه 2008
واطلق عليها
البقاله عليها وكان الغرض منها هي امتصاص
الخسائر في حاله حدوث ازمات حاده كما تحدث
الان وتكون هي الجزء الاول او
بامتصاص الخسائر حتى لا يتاثر المذيعون
وغيرهم من حمله السندات الاعلى المساهمين
في هذه الحاله بيتم
انخطاب راس مال الشركه الى حد كبير وهذا
الحد
هو الذي
يبدا عنه
هذه السندات فبالتالي بنقول هما اللير
الاولاني او الشريحه الاولانيه هم الكوكوز
وبعد هذا ياتي المساهمين فبالتالي ماذا
حدث بقى في هذه الاسهم هذه الاسهم من
يمتلكها يمتلكها كثير جدا من
الهيدس
والمؤسسات التامين وغيرها لانها تدر عائد
في المرتفع
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن تداعيات هذه
الازمه على الاقتصاد العالمي والنظام
المالي العالمي سينضم اليه بالاستديو وليد
حلو مدير ابحاث السوق في امانه كابيتال
استاذ وليد يعني كنا عندما حدث موضوع
سيليكون فالي نتحدث عن ازمه البنوك
الصغيره اليوم تحولت الى ازمه بالبنوك
الكبيره ومن الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا
ماذا يعني ذلك وهل يمكن لعمل خوف يعني ان
يبقى هذه السلسله مفتوحه سلسله الانهيارات
بالضبط زي ما تفضلت الاسواق بتسعر مخاوف
جديده عشان كده انتقلت مباشره
لبنك ضعيف وضعيف جدا وهو كريد سويس اللي
كان عليه يمكن من عشرين عشرين عنده اكتر
من مشكله من اول
غسيل الاموال للانتقال لخسائر كبيره حصلت
مع عرق ارشيغوس كابيتال لاسوا نتايج ربعيه
حصلت كانت موجوده للعمل الماضي واداره
جديده وكان اساسا قدامهم ثلاث سنين عشان
يرجعوا للربحيه مره اخرى فكانت بنك ده
ضحيه لهذا الضغط اللي موجود بسحب الايداع
او او بسحب كبير استقبال كبير على سحب
الودائع الخاصه هنا يعني السؤال الذي يطرح
هناك العديد من المستثمرين سيقاضون البنوك
ودائما العنوان هو بيانات ماليه كاذبه هل
يستطيع البنك ان يقدم بيانات ماليه كاذبه
ولا يكشف عن ازمه ماليه يعني موجوده او
ازمه سيوله بالضبط هو ده اللي حصل يمكن
الاس اي سي اللي هي الوكاله المسؤوله عن
التنظيم العمل في السوق الامريكي لما تم
تقديم التقرير الثانوي الخاص بالكريدي
سويس كان لها ملاحظات وبناء على هذه
الملاحظات هو ده اللي بدا بدا هذه المشكله
لان كان في اخطاء محاسبيه كبيره موجوده
ولكن النوعيه حتى سجنه يعني نفس العنوان
النفس العنوان فهي فكره ودي اهميه الدور
الرقابه الماليه اللي موجوده عندنا حاليا
واللي ايضا بالاضافه لان انت بتراقب اللي
بيحصل في البنك ايضا بتراقب المستويات
الخاصه من الحاجات اللي زي كده عشان تتاكد
ان هي في مكانها السليم وايضا التامين
اللي بيكون بالنسبه للحكومه واللي بيساعد
بصوره كبيره على التعويض باختصار اليوم
يعني كنا نتحدث عن ان هذه الازمه لا تشبه
ازمه لعام 2018 بسبب الدروس المستفاده
وبسبب الاجراءات التي تقوم بها البنوك
المركزيه ما الفرق لماذا لا تشبه يعني
ازمه عام 2008 لانها ازمه سيوله هي دي
بمنتهى البساطه احنا بنوجه دلوقتي ازمه
سيوله موجوده في البنوك الصغيره والمتخصصه
والبنوك اللي فيها سوء اداره بصوره واضحه
وعشان كده كل الاسماء اللي كانت موجوده
لما بنبص على التفاصيل هنلاقي كان في سوق
اداره موجود خلال الفتره الماضيه هو اللي
ادى لهذا الضغط ولكن الفكره الفوارق اللي
موجوده وخصوصا في كريد السويس
الحكومه
والاسمبي المركزي السويسري وكل هذه الجهات
يعني حافظت على ان يتم الاستحواذ ما بينها
وما بين يو بي اس لان الكريدي سويس اسم
كبير مقارنه بالبنوك التلاته اللي انهارت
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم يعني
هناك نقطه ايضا يشار اليها بان ستكون هناك
مشكله اكبر بالتعاطي مع ما يعرف بالوازع
الاخلاقي اي تعويض يعني المذيعين
والمستثمرين اكثر من الولايات المتحده
خصوصا ان هناك مخاوف من ان تنسحب ازمه هذا
البنك على بنوك اخرى لماذا النقطه مهمه
جدا دلوقتي تركيز الرئيسي على ما يسمى
المخاوف اللي موجوده واللي كانت موجوده في
الازمه الماليه العالميه ان الحكومه صرفت
اموال طائله من دافعه ضرائب على حاجه
واحده بس على تمويل اخطاء البنوك اللي
كانت موجوده في 2008 واليوم هذا مرفوض
مرفوض تماما فعشان كده كل صور المساعدات
اللي موجوده حتى ال 100 مليار فرانكل اللي
تم دعمها مثلا من الحكومه
السويسريه كانت واضحه وصريحه هي ليست ولكن
هي نوع من انواع القرض اللي هيكون موجود
نفس الموضوع بالنسبه للفدرالي الامريكي
فهي
الضغط كبير بالنسبه على الحكومه لان
دافعيه ضرائب مش عايزين يكونوا مسؤولين
على اخطاء
بالنسبه للقطاع البنكي اللي موجود عندنا
وده يمكن بترتيب الخطوره بالنسبه لي
بريطانيا هي الاكبر وبعديها الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبعد كده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اللي اعتقد ان هي تمتلك اقوى
تشريع ممكن الغد دلوقتي المستثمرين
والمودعين بالعالم العربي وحتى بالعالم
اجمع كانوا يتجهون الى البنوك الامريكيه
والاوروبيه الايداع اموالهم اليوم ما يحصل
من انهيارات يعني متتاليه هناك كيف ستؤثر
طبعا هي اثرت على بعض المستثمرين هناك
ولكن كيف ستؤثر على الاسواق البنكيه
العربيه يمكن احنا سمعنا انباء جدا كويسه
وده اللي انا كنت اتمنى اسمعه بصوره كبيره
وخصوصا من المملكه العربيه السعوديه يمكن
محافظه بنك المركزي اشار بعدم وجود اي
اكسبوجر على البنوك في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واتكلم ايضا على النسب بتاعه
البنوك السعوديه وكان نسب جدا مميزه
مقارنه بالبنوك العالميه اعتقد ان الخليج
بصوره عامه القطاع البنكي جدا جدا مميز
وما عندوش نفس السيستماتيك ريسك اللي
موجود بره شكرا لك استاذ وليد الحلو مدير
ابحاث السوق في امانه كابيتال على وجودك
معنا
[موسيقى]
يواجه بان كوكري سويس الذي تم تاسيسه منذ
اكثر من 160 عاما سلسله من الفضائح خلال
السنوات الماضيه كلفته مليارات الدولارات
وتعرض ثاني اكبر بنك في سويسرا لغرامات
وعقوبات تتعلق بتهم عده ابرزها تهم غسل
الاموال والاحتيال الضاربي ففي فبراير من
عام 2020 تعرضت قديس سويس لفضيحه تجسس في
البنك ادت الى رحيل رئيسه التنفيذي تيجان
تيام استهدفت كبار المديرين السابقين
ومنظمات وفي مارس 2020 الدانهيار صندوق
الاستثمارات الامريكي
خسائر قدرها 5 مليارات و500 مليون دولار
بسبب انكشافه على الصندوق وفي الشهر نفسه
اضطر البنك السويسري الى تجميد عشره
مليارات دولار من صناديق تمويل سلاسل
الامداد المرتبطه بجرينسيل
الخدمات الماليه البريطانيه المفلسه التي
سوقها المنكو لعملائه على انها منتجات
منخفضه الخطوره وفي عام 2021
استقال انطونيو هورتا اوسوريو من منصب
رئيس مجلس الاداره بعد اقل من تسعه اشهر
من انضمامه
قواعد الحجر الصحي الخاصه بكورونا وفي
اكتوبر عام 2022 اعلنت عن خطه شامله
لاعاده التركيز على الخدمات البنكيه
للاثرياء بجانب جامعي راس مال بقيمه 4
مليارات فرنك سويسري وتخفيض عدد الموظفين
بواقع تسعه الاف بحلول نهايه عام 2025
وفصل خدماته البنكيه الاستثماريه في وحده
جديده
وخلال الشهر الحالي اشارت تقرير السنوي
لخدي سويس الى اوجهي ضعف جوهريه في الض
وابط الداخليه لاعداد التقارير الماليه
سعى حمدان العربيه
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى مبادره السلام
الصينيه ورد الان بتصريحات في من البيت
الابيض ننصح الرئيس الصيني بان يتحدث الى
زيلينسكي وايضا البيت الابيض يقول ننصح
الرئيس الصيني بان يدعم سياده الدول
وتعمل على تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي للشعب
الفلسطيني هذا شيء اخر واذا بموضوع الصين
هم طبعا يشددون ويعيدون التاكيد بان يجب
الحديث مع الرئيس الاوكراني الحديث مع
الرئيس الروسي بان يدعم سياده الدول
وبالتالي هنا الحديث عن ضروره انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه قبل
الحديث عن مبادره سلام وبالتالي عدم
التنازل عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه للرئيس
الروسي
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
اتفاق بين وفدي الحكومه اليمنيه وميليشيات
الحوثي للافراج عن 880 اسيرا ومختطفا
[موسيقى]
وتعهدت المفوضيه الاوروبيه بتقديم مليار
يورو لتعم اعاده الاعمار في تركيا لمواجهه
تداعيات الزلزال وخلال مؤتمر للمانحين في
بروكسيل لدعم ضحايا زلزال اوضحت رئيسه
المفوضيه ارسولا فوندر لاين ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيقدم 108 ملايين يورو لتمويل
العمليات الانسانيه في سوريا
يسعدني ان اعلن عن دعم المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لتركيا بمليار يورو لاعاده الاعمار بعد
الزلزال وسنقدم حزمه المساعدات ب 180
ملايين يورو لتمويل العمليات الانسانيه في
سوريا واعاده التاهيل وعلاوه على ذلك
تعهدت المؤسسات الماليه الاوروبيه بتقديم
حزب مساعدات اضافيه
بدوره قال الرئيس التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان
ان حجم الخسائر بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب 10
ولايات تركيه في السادس من الشهر الماضي
قد يصل الى 104 مليار دولار
تشير التقديرات الى ان تكلفه الدمار
الناجم عن الزلزال ستصل الى قرابه 104
مليارات دولار ولا يمكن لاي دوله ان
تتعامل مع كارثه بهذا الحجم وحدها بغض
النظر عن القدرات الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل حيث اعلنت المعارضه انها ستقدم
طعنا امام المحكمه العليا ضد مشروع
القانون المقدم من رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو لتعديل قواعد تعيين القضاه وقال
زعيم المعارضه يا ايرلابيد انه سيقدم
الطعن في اللحظه التي سيتم فيها تمرير
التعديلات على لجنه التعيينات القضائيه
وتشهد اسرائيل احتجاجات كبيره ضد قانون
تغيير النظام القضائي
لاول مره بعد اسابيع من الاحتجاجات في
اسرائيل البيت الابيض يدخل على خط تسويه
سياسيه بعد تصاعد حده التوتر بسبب مشروع
تعديل النظام القضائي الذي طرحه الرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
وايجاد تسويه او حل
وسط طبعا بين الحكومه من جهه والمعارضه من
جهه اخرى امر شدد عليها الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن في اتصال هاتفي
ان الاصلاحات يجب ان تحترم ما اسماها
القيم الديمقراطيه الاساسيه كما تحدث
بايدن عن الحاجه الى ضوابط وتوازنات للسعي
للحصول على دعم واسع عند اجراء تغييرات
جوهريه ورغم الضغوط الخارجيه والداخليه
قرر حزب الليكود الذي يتزعمه نتنياهو
المضي قدما بالتغييرات لمنح الحكومه قدره
اكثر حسما على اختيار القضاه بحلول الثاني
من اي بري عندما يدخل البرلمان في عطله
لمده شهر هذا المشهد مشاهدينا اعتبرته
صحيفه هارت كابوسا على واشنطن الاستعداد
له تحديدا بعدما رفضت حكومه نتنياهو خطه
الاصلاح القضائي التي اقترحها الرئيس
الاسرائيلي والتي كانت بمثابه حل وسط ليحل
محل مخطط الحكومه المتطرفه البعيد المدى
والذي من شانه ان يضعف النظام القضائي
ويمنح سلطات غير مقيده للحكومه والكنيسه
تقول طبعا هنا الصحيفه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان ان عشرات القضايا مرفوعه ضده لاسباب
سياسيه او اضافه خان في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه بان الهدف من هذه القضايا هو
ابعاده عن الانتخابات
هناك نحو مئات قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والارهاب وحتى
قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل شخص كل هذه
القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه لابعاد على
الانتخابات فالمشكله هي ان المعارضه تعرف
تماما انها لا تستطيع الفوز بالانتخابات
ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه البالغ عددها
37 مقعدا فزنا بثلاثين منها فهم قلقون من
ان مشاركتنا في انتخابات الثلاثين من
ابريل ستلحق الهزيمه بهم وهم يخشون من ذلك
وهم يحاولون ابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات من
خلال اقامه كل هذه الدعوه وضدي
هذا وقال ايضا رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان ان الحكومه لم توفر له
الحمايه خلال جلسات المحاكمه واضاف في
مقابله خاصه مع العربيه بان حياتهم مهدده
ورغم ذلك حضر كل الجلسات باستثناء واحده
بسبب اصابته خلال محاوله اغتياله الاخيره
سبق ان حضرت جلسات المحاكمه كلها والمره
الوحيده التي تخلفت فيها عن الحضور كانت
بعد اصابته اثناء المحاوله التي تعرضت
فيها للاغتيال والتي حالت دون الذهاب الى
المحكمه لمده اربعه اشهر لكنني كنت مقعدا
في البيت بسبب اصابه في قدمه قبلها كنت
اذهب الى كل جلسات المحاكمه مع عدا واحده
وسبب ذلك هو ان مبنى المحكمه غير امن فهم
لم يوفروا لي الحمايه وحياتي كانت مهدده
على الرغم من ان الحكومه اعلنت ان حياتي
مهدده الا انها لم توفر للحمايه وفي تلك
المحكمه حصلت قبل ذلك عمليتين ارهابيتين
نجمتا عن مقتل قضاه ومحامين وعندما نقلت
المحاكمه الى المجمع القضائي
ذهبت الى هناك يوم السبت ومثلت امام هيئه
المحكمه
تتابعنا مشاهدينا المقابله كامله التي
اجرتها الزميله ريمبو غامرا مع رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان يوم
الاربعاء اي غدا في تمام الساعه السادسه
عشر بتوقيت غرينتش والسابعه بتوقيت الرياض
اذا المقابله يوم الاربعاء بعد غد
ينضم الينا من لاهور عبد الرحمن المزيني
مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن يعني بموازات
هذه التصريحات التي سمعناها
لعمران خان ما هي الاجواء هناك وما الجديد
بالقضيه
ليالي ابدا هنا من اجتماع الذي عقده
الائتلاف الحاكم في باكستان واستمر لنحو
سته ساعات هذا الاجتماع افضل بعده توصيات
وقرارات لعل من ابرزها
استنكار ما وصفها الاعتداء على هيبه
الدوله وقوات الامن الباكستانيه من قبل
عناصر
ونشاطاء نشطاء التابعين لحزب حزب
الانصاف بزعامه عمران خان الاجتماع دعا
ايضا او ندد ايضا بما وصفها الحملات
التحريضيه التي يتعرض لها الجيش
الباكستاني وقائد الجيش الباكستاني الفريق
اول عاصم منير الاجتماع ايضا دعا الى الى
جلسه مشتركه للبرلمان الباكستاني بشقيه
مجلسي الشيوخ
والنواب يوم الاربعاء المقبل لاتخاذ ما
وصفها بقرارات مهمه لاستمرار
عجله الدوله وسير الدوله في ظل حاله
التوتر السياسي في البلاد واذا هناك حاله
من التصعيد والاتهامات المتبادله بين كل
من الحكومه الباكستانيه وحزب الانصاف
بزعامه عمران خان عمران خان كان في وقت
سابق نفى اتهامات الحكومه له
بانتقاد الجيش او التعرض للجيش او القيام
بحملات مناهضه للجيش وقال ان الجيش
الباكستاني هو جيشه وان الحكومه تحاول دق
اسفين
والتحريض ما بينه وبين الجيش الباكستاني
ايضا عمران خان قال بان الحكومه
الباكستانيه لم يكن هدفها من خلال هذه
القضايا التي
ضده لاسيما الحضور الاخيره ومثور والاخير
امام محكمه جنائيه في اسلام اباد انه لم
يكن الهدف لحضوره وانما كان هناك مخطط
لاغتياله عبر اثاره واستثاره
مناصرين واثاره الفوضى واراقه الدماء ان
يكون هذاك غطاء
لقتله
بعد ما حضر الجلسه عمران خان يعني بالايام
القادمه ما المتوقع ان يحصل
كما تعلمين انه تم رفع الجلسه الى تاريخ
الثلاثين من هذا الشهر من المقرر ان يمثل
او من المفترض ان يمثل عمران خان امام
الجلسه لكن هناك لنقل العديد من القضايا
التي من المقرر ان يمثل لها
او اليوم تقريبا تم رفع ايضا
محضرين بتهم الارهاب ضد رئيس وزراء السابق
عمران خان لكن الفريق القانوني العمران
خان تقدم بالتماسات لبعض
المحكمه العليا هنا في اسلام اباد لمنحه
كفاله مؤقته قابله للتمديد
ضد اي مذكره اعتقاد محتمله على خلفيه
القضيه اود الاشاره الى انه في موازاه ذلك
هناك كانت حمله امنيه لاعتقاد مناصري
وانصار ونشطاء حزب انصاف بزعامه عمران خان
نتحدث عن ربما بضعه مئات من انصاره تم
قالوهم لا سيما في مدينه لاغور ومدينه
اسلام اباد تم تسجيل محاضر وبلغات ضد
العشرات من نشطاء حزب الانصاف بعض قاده
حزب الانصاف تمكنوا من الحصول على كفالات
مؤقته مؤقته ضد الاعتقال الحزب يتهم
الحكومه بانها تسعى لمنعه من خوض
الانتخابات المقبله في ظل شعورها بانها
سوف تخسر هذه الانتخابات حسب ما يقول قاده
وزعماء حزب الانصاف
شكرا
[موسيقى]
على تبادل 887 اسيرا اضافه الى العوده في
شهر مايو القادم لاستكمال المفاوضات حول
صفقه تبادل اخرى واصفا للخطوه بالايجابيه
اختتم اليوم بنتائج ايجابيه اتفاق الوفتان
على خطه التنفيذ
للافراج عند 887
محتجز من الجانبين
اتفقوا اذا على الالتقاء مجددا في منتصف
ما يلي بحث المزيد من الاسرى الذين
سيفرجوا عنهم
وتم ايضا التركيز على السماح بالوصول الى
كافه الاسرى
الطرفين اللذين يتواجدان اليوم
للحوار البناء والتفاوض بحسن نيه لتوصل
الى هذه النتيجه من خلال تنازلات الضروريه
التاسع مشاهدينا وفيها بعد اقل
موجه تسريحات ضخمه تجتاح امازون الشركه
ستستغني عن تسعه الاف موظف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خلال يومين قادمين قد
يواجه دوله ترامب الاتهامات رسميا في قضيه
الممثله الاباحيه وفقا لما افاد مسؤولون
امريكيون مضيفين انه اذا حصل ذلك فسيتم
بحث وصول ترامب للمحكمه مع جهاز الخدمه
السريه والشرطه نيويورك وعدم وعن قدره
المدعي العام لمن هاته على وضع الاصفاد
بيد رعب الجبل مسؤولون الامريكيون بنعم
انها من صلاحياته هذا واتهم رؤساء لجان في
مجلس النواب الامريكي المدعي العام في
منهاتن
بالاساءه لسلطه الادعاء وطلبه بالادلاء
بشهادته حول قرار مقاضات ترامب بدوره قال
عمده نيويورك ان الامر متروك للمدعي العام
الامر متروك
وسمعنا الكثير من التقارير لكن المدعي
العام سيتخذ هذا القرار ونحن سنفعل ما
نفعله دائما كما تعلمون نحن نراقب
التعليقات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتؤدي شرطه نيويورك دورها الطبيعي في
التاكد من عدم وجود اجراءات غير لائقه في
المدينه نحن على ثقه اننا سنكون قادرين
على القيام بذلك دي مايكل كاهن هو محامي
عمل لمصلحه دونالد ترامب منذ 2006 حتى
مايو 2018
في يونيو 2018 بدا تحقيق فيدراليون ضده
ودين عام 2019 بجرائم تشمل التهرب الضريبي
والكذب على الكونجرس وتسهيل مدفوعات غير
قانونيه عام 2016 رتب لدفع 150 الف دولار
لشراء حقوق قصه العارضه السابقه كارن
ماكدوغان التي زعمت فيها اقامه علاقه مع
ترامب عام 2016 ايضا صربت له مقاطع مع
ترامب حول قضيه كارين عام 2003
استعداده للشهاده ضد ترامب في قضيه شراء
الصمت ستومي دانيت
المدعي العام في منهات الفن براق يقود
محاكمه مشحونه سياسيا
[موسيقى]
التحقيق مع ترامب اساءه استخدام شنيعه
للسلطه من قبل يسار راديكالي توجيه تهمه
جنائيه بحق ترامب كانت مجرد دليل على مدى
خوف الديمقراطيين
قد تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه لكنها اشبه
باجواء ما قبل العاصفه عاصفه رياحها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
ان سيطر على شاشات التلفزه بدعوه انصاره
لتنظيم احتجاجات حاشده
الاحتجاجات المرتقبه اقلقت السلطات
الامريكيه من تكرار سيناريو اقتحام
الكابيتول الاميركي على يد مناصري ترامب
وامكانيه خروجها عن نطاق السيطره وتحولها
الى عمليات عنف وتخريب وفيما يشبه الهجوم
المضاد ندد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارثي بتحقيق المدعي العام بحق
ترامب واصفا الامر بالمسيس رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن ماكارتي
لا يهم اي جانب من المشكله انت الان لا
يهم ما اذا كان هذا هو الرئيس ترامب او
اذا كان ديمقراطيا يجب ان تكون هذه عداله
متساويه في امريكا وان تتوقف عن ملاحقه
الناس لان لديهم خلافات سياسيه
دعوه ترامب للتصعيد في الشارع رافقها
تاييد من كبار المسؤولين ابرزهم السيناتور
الذي حثت رمب على المقاومه واخذ القضيه
الى المحكمه العليا
تصعيد الجمهوريين قابله اخر ديمقراطي
بدعوى ان ما يجري محاولات جديده لخدمه
مصالح ترامب
السيناتور الديمقراطيه اليزابيث
هذه حاله اخرى
لمصالح باقيه الامه لنكن واضحين بشان ما
يحدث هنا لا احد فوق القانون ولا حتى
الرئيس السابق للولايات المتحده
التصعيد الحاصل بين جمهوري وديمقراطي يبقي
الشارع الاميركي ومعه العالم مترقبا لما
سينتهي اليه الامر امر قد ياخذ اميركا الى
ابعد من هذا المشهد
للمزيد ينضم الينا من واشنطن حسين الطوب
مراسل العربيه حسين يعني هذا الانقسام
الحاصل على المستوى القانوني السياسي بين
الحزبين وفي الشارع ايضا ما هي اخر تجليات
اليوم
بالفعل ليال هو انقسام عمودي اذا صح
التعبير سياسيا واجتماعيا هنا في الولايات
المتحده بشان ما اذا كان سيتم توجيه لائحه
الاتهام للترامبو كيف ستكون رده فعله ولكن
قبل الوصول الى هذه النقطه الان من
المنتظر ان يقدم روبرت كوستيو هو محامي
ومستشار سابق لمحامي ترامب السابق مايكل
شهادته امام
اللجنه هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في نيويورك
كوستيو كان ابلغ محاميه ترامب بان لديه
معلومات قد تضحت كل ما قاله
وايضا تبرئ الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من
التوم الموجهه اليه بعد هذه الشهاده سنعرف
ما اذا كانت هذه الهيئه ستوجه بالفعل
التهم الى ترامب ام لا لانه اذا بالفعل
استطاع ان يقدم ادله بري ترامب فعندها من
المستبعد ان توجه لدنا ترامب تهم وتامر
باعتقالها الان اذا تم توجيه هذه التهم
من مذكره الاعتقال اذا تمت بالفعل احسان
اذا تمت مذكره الاعتقال الدستور الامريكي
يقول بان المدانين المجرمين يمكن ان
يتابعوا اعمالهم وشغلهم في المناصب
المختارين فيها وبالتالي ممكن ان يتابع
الحمله الانتخابيه من داخل السجن
العيال عن هذا السؤال طرحته على اكثر من
محلل سياسي هنا وحتى من خبراء في القانون
الامريكي سالتهم عن هذا الموضوع هل اذا
ادينا الترامب هل هناك من يمنعه دستوريا
قالوا لا يوجد شيء امثله على ذلك بانه
هناك في التاريخ الامريكي بالفعل احد
المسجونين وقد تقدم ورشح نفسه لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالدستور
الامريكي لا يوجد ما يمنعه ليكون مرشحا
للشعب الامريكي ليكون في منصب الرئاسه
الامريكيه هذا ما يقال لنا وهذا ما ينص
عليه الدستور الامريكي وفقه هؤلاء الخبراء
نعم شكرا لك الزميل لحسين الطوط حدثتنا من
واشنطن
نبقى مشاهدينا في الولايات المتحده حيث
تسربت اكثر من مليون لتر من المياه
الملوثه بالمواد المشعه من محطه للطاقه
النوويه في ولايه
مينيسويا واكدت الشرطه او من الشرطه واكدت
الشرطه التي تدير المحطه ان التسرب تم
احتوائه بصوره كامله في الموقع ولم تقع اي
مخاطر صحيه نتيجه التسرب الذي حدث في
نوفمبر الماضي ولم يكشف عنه سوى قبل ايام
قليله وتحتوي المياه المتسربه على ماده
التريتيوم المشعه والتي تنتج بشكل ثانوي
اثناء تشغيل المحطه النوويه
هذا ونقلت شبكه ام بي سي الامريكيه عن
رساله داخليه في شركه امازون انها ابلغت
الموظفين بعمليه تسريح اضافيه لتسعه الاف
موظف واعلنت امازون في يناير الماضيه عن
تسريح اكثر من 18 الف موظف في عده اقسام
منها المتاجر والموارد البشريه ليبلغ ذلك
اجمالي من سيتم تسريحهم لسبعه وعشرين
وعشرين الف موظف هذا وكانت امازون عززت
عمليه التوظيف بشكل كبير خلال العامين
الماضيين خلال جائحه كورونا والان تعاني
بسبب الازمه الاقتصاديه وتقوم بتسريح
الالاف منهم
[موسيقى]
اعتمد البرلمان الفرنسي قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد وذلك بعدما نجحت الحكومه ونجت من
التصويتين لحجب الثقه عنها امام مجلس
النواب وتمكنت حكومه ماكرون من النجاه
بفارق ضئيل حيث صوت
278 نائبا لصالح سحب الثقه وهو اقل بتسعه
اصوات عن المطلوبه لحجب الثقه هذا وتواجه
الحكومه هذا التصويت بسبب رفض قانون
التقاعد الذي قدمه
ضمن سلسله التطورات للاحتجاجات في فرنسا
اقدم خمسين محتجا على حرق عجلات سيارات
واعتراض منتصف الطريق الرئيسي من خلال وضع
تلك العجلات في الطريق حتى تمنع من الوصول
الى محرقه النفايات
ومحطه التدفئه الحضاريه في فرنسا هذا
وتشهد فرنسا وتيره متصاعده من الاحتجاجات
بعدما قرر الرئيس امام المعروفه تمرير
قانون رفع سن التقاعد
وهذه مشاهدينا صور مباشره للاحتجاجات
الليليه في شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
بعد اعتماد البرلمان لقانون التقاعد ورفع
سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى اربعه وستين
عاما واصدر رفض طبعا
النقابات العماليه والاحزاب اليمينيه ايضا
لهذا القانون مما دفع الرئاسه الفرنسيه
الى تمرير القانون دون تصويت عليه في
البرلمان حيث كان يعني من
المحسون بانه لن يمر
[موسيقى]
انطلقت اليوم اذاعه العربيه اف ام من
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض والتي تقدم تغطيه
للاخبار السياسيه والاقتصاديه والرياضيه
على مدار الساعه اضافه الى رصد ومواكبه
الاخبار العاجله محليا وعالميا وتضم
الاذاعه شبكه من المراسلين في كل انحاء
العالم فنتابع
قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره شاشه يمتد
عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان تعرف اكثر
مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان جاء دور
الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
ولدت اذاعه العربيه العربيه اف ام تضعك في
الصوره لتعرف اكثر
ومن قلب استوديوهات الاخبار بالرياض اذاعه
العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل المستمعين
حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي وقت اتمنى ان يصلكم
الخبر فور حدوثه واينما كنتم بالصوت
والكلمه سنقدم لك كل ما يهمك ان تعرفه عبر
صباح العربيه اف ام
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الخزاعه
المشوار بخطه ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام
الختام مشاهدينا مع العناوين
من موسكو الرئيسان الصيني والروسي يؤكدان
على عالم جديد متعدد الاقطاب وواشن تعلق
يتحالفون ضد امريكا
الحل الطارئ لازمه كريدي سويس ينعش الاسهم
واسهم البنوك الامريكيه وبنوك مركزيه
عالميه تتحرك لتوفير السيول الدولار
عمران خان في مقابلات خاصه مع العربيه
هناك 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضدي ودوافعها
السياسيه
يتهم المدعي العام بمنهات بالتدخل في
انتخابات عام 2024 والاخير قد يوجه
اتهاماته خلال يومين
ناتي الى ختام التاسعه لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره الان الى 360 مع الزميله ريم
بوجمره مساء الخير يا ريم مساء الخير
منوره يا ريم شكرا اليوم قبل ان اسالك
ماذا لديك اليوم عيد السعاده ماذا تقولي
لكل الزملاء والمشاهدين ان شاء الله كل
عام وهم سعداء مثل ما هم سعداء دائما ان
شاء الله وانت سعيده كما نحن سعداء ابدا
تفضلي ماذا لديك الليله لدي مواضيع كثيره
اقول لك المواضيع ولكن على شرط قولي لي
مواضيعك
للمساعده
لدينا حركه الاسهم يبدو بانها تتعافى ولكن
ماذا عن البنوك والنظام المصرفي سنطرح
اسئله بخصوص هذا الموضوع لدينا زياره رئيس
الصيني الى روسيا ولدينا كذلك موضوع ترامب
بقصصه وتطوراته ولكن كل هذا بعد قليل تفضل